ten days until brexit will we still be
in or out Boris Johnson desperate to
leave on time and trying to pass his
deal at breakneck speed but Parliament
putting obstacles in his way the speaker
rejecting the Prime Minister's attempt
at a meaningful vote today they had
their chance on Saturday it is clear
that the motions are in substance the
same the motion will not be debated
today as it would be repetitive and
disorderly to do so Boris Johnson's
backers exasperated the only consistency
one can find in your rulings is that
they always seem to favor one side of
the argument and never the government
who are trying their best to carry out
the mandate given to them by the British
people in 2016 I don't agree with him I
think the consistent thread is that I
try to do what I think is right by the
House of Commons this road right by the
House of Commons is closed and so is the
government's preferred path to
delivering brexit so to plan B the
government published its brexit bill in
the hope it can race it through
Parliament before Halloween but the
deadline could shift the PM has
requested an extension from the EU
despite saying he'd rather die in a
ditch the Prime Minister has not deign
to grace us with his presence today but
I'm reassured Mr Speaker that despite
his pledge he's not to be found anywhere
in a ditch despite having told the
British public over and over again he
would never do it the letter has in fact
been sent can the Secretary of State
tell the house when he expects any
extension to be granted no answer on
that the PM desperate to avoid delay
what the Prime Minister made clear is
that we would abide by the law and what
Lord Panik has confirmed amongst many
others is that the Prime Minister has
done so this are more complicated and
dangerous paths
one the government would have preferred
to avoid Parliament might want more time
to scrutinize the new legislation
pushing his deadline out of reach and
parliamentarians on both sides of the
brexit divide could seek to amend the
bill
you probably want me to tell you whether
we're going to be leaving with a deal or
no deal on October the 31st but in truth
I simply don't know and neither do the
MPs in that place behind me the
meaningful vote delayed today the next
crucial moment could come on Wednesday
when the government's expected to try
and pass brexit legislation through the
House of Commons at the moment it looks
like the numbers could be there but
there's a fly in the ointment
because if MPs decide to amend that bill
and put in something Boris Johnson can't
live with such as a customs union well
then the Prime Minister might decide to
pull the bill entirely so we could end
the week with a deal but we could end
the week in gridlock still three years
of debate boiling down into three
crucial days time for Parliament decide
whether it backs this deal or not as for
what comes next still to be decided Beth
Rigby Sky News Westminster